in terms of digital challenges Zach I
was looking through a magazine and I
have with the call I'm happy to follow
photographs of Zach where Zach was
casually walking down the street with no
shirt on
and much higher let's pep talk and it
would be leaning against a parking meter
I think we've got the picture here now
photo shoot Makarov here try to be it
was it we have one at the Apple go ahead
those trying to take the parking meter
off yeah yeah Lars really doing that or
otherwise yet now he's doing it oh no
yeah that's a now he's doing it yeah
okay yeah not that I'm calling you a
liar but over the pole right over there
[Laughter]
[Applause]
couple you wanted to do though do it can
you yeah no no no you can't do this
right you tested this thing it's not
it's not solid this is videos it's being
tested it's being tested here we're not
sure of her name but
Hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
Wow begun baladeva better than the
photoshoot
yeah I was Wow did I get flat you know
yeah perfect you'll love it I'm so happy
I could still do that so are we
and I would have been yeah but I hired a
pole
[Music]